the number of people infected with
corona virus serves by more than 3000
overnight as experts worried it could
become a pandemic this morning in the
epicenter city of Wuhan a newly built
hospital dedicated to treating the virus
started to accept new patients more than
420 people have died in China and more
than 20,000 people have become sick
worldwide mola legi is at Princeton
University that's in New Jersey where
about 100 students who recently
travelled to China were required to
quote self quarantine mola good morning
I'm not sure what that is doesn't sound
good though how are the students doing
oh yeah good morning Tony five students
here on campus are still being assessed
but school officials told us this
morning that Noah no students at any
point have shown any signs or symptoms
of coronaviruses has been precautionary
the requirement to self quarantine as
part of federal and state guidelines but
you know it shows it's just another
indication of how fears of this rapidly
spreading virus are spreading throughout
the country here in the United States
more than 7,000 miles from where this
outbreak began you afraid to go out
because there is a lot of panic
everywhere as the corona virus leaves
parts of China in a seemingly
never-ending lockdown I think is quite
safe to go outside now if you don't
instruct this people some countries are
taking extreme measures to stop its
spread Australia sent hundreds of
evacuees from Wuhan to a remote island
in the Indian Ocean for at least two
weeks to monitor them for symptoms in
Japan officials quarantine thousands of
cruise ship passengers after a Hong Kong
man who sailed on it last month tested
positive for the virus and in Hong Kong
more than 2,000 medical workers went on
strike demanding that the government
close all its borders with mainland
China the crisis is far-reaching
coronavirus cases have spread to more
than two dozen countries two deaths have
been identified outside of mainland
China but the World Health Organization
called some countries restrictions
excessive there is no reason for
measures that unnecessarily interfere
with international travel and trade in
the US officials have identified a
second case of human to human
transmission this time in kal
fornia the CDC is currently monitoring
82 people for potential infection what
is there to still be concerned about in
some cases a person without symptoms
seems to have transmitted the virus how
often does that happen dr. Mark Mulligan
is head of infectious diseases at NYU
Langone in New York City it seems that
the virus spreads fairly easily and when
when you're not isolating cases quickly
and quarantine in contacts quickly
they're now doing that in China we're
doing that here how effective those
measures will be again is something that
worries me
hello Department of Health and Human
Services announced yesterday that it's
making nearly 250 million dollars in
emergency funds available to respond to
the recur onna virus that'll include
funds that will go towards screening and
monitoring returning US citizens Tony
who were expected back here in the
United States in the coming weeks a lot
of money there hope it helps mola thank
you very much
you